Cela fait maintenant près d'un an qu'il a prit sa retraite
Il dessinait comme un dieu
Chaque feuille qu'il touchait se transformait en véritable œuvre d'art
Mais aujourd'hui pour votre plus grand plaisir,
il a dû mal à parler
OK, salut je vais ranger ce critérium parce qu'il sert à rien
2016 c'est tout éléctronique hein
Aujourd'hui on est sur "Quick, Draw"
C'est un jeu fait par Google
Google, la famille, toi même tu sais, ceux qui me payent tous les mois merci hein
C'est parti
On va devoir dessiner "saw"
c'est quoi "saw" ? Moi je connais le film, j'connais....
une scie , ah oui !
Okay c'est parti
Il voit une montagne
Il voit une étoile
Il voit un avion
*rire*
il m'étonne le con , je peux reset éventuellement
Allez
Heu une scie moi je, la scie heu la scie vénère
ça
je vois un 'zigzag' , non mais non la 'scie' comme ça
bon , bah j'sais pas , mais attends mec comment tu veux représenter une scie
Oh le blaireau
ah mais oui moi je pensais a la scie sauteuse !!!!!!!!!!
j'pensais à celle la , nan ?
eh mec je crois je joue vraiment trop au jeux vidéo
j'imaginais ah ... bah un shuriken en fait
voilà il m'a demandé de faire  une scie j'ai fait un shuriken
dessines une main , très très simple
On fait le poignet ça s’élargit un petit peu pour le pouce
Les quatre autres doigts
OH je sais c'est une main
attends il avait marqué
ah nan c'est bon j'ai réussi
dessines une barbe , c'est très simple on va reproduire ça
*musique épique*
bon c'est pas parce que j'ai de la barbe que je sais dessiner de la barbe ok ça vous va ?
dessine un cookie , très simple
il voit une potatoe ...wtf
il voit une potatoe blueberry
oh on a ... ah il m'as fais peur
un patate , mais c'est moi qui vais t'en mettre une , UNE PATATE
dessine un pantalon bah bien sur
un chandelier
ah voila
putin il me fais plaisir
je fais vraiment le dessin de base une voiture
la on va mettre un petit peu de 3D sa va etre *bisous* al dente
*musique épique*
j ai fais une soucoupe volante
lui il voit un hamburger donc je sais pas trop comment le prendre *il faut le prendre mal...*
mais attendez le logiciel a reconnu 5 de tes dessin et il a vu autres choses d'en l'un d'eux
il as vu un bracelet , ensuite un cercle
et ensuite un anvil
c'est évident que c'est une scie google !
c'est évident regarder cette ressemblance ! vous avez rarement
vu une scie aussi bien faites ! PLAY AGAIN !
alors que-ce qu'il va nous demander de faire ? une petite fleur ?
la fleur de l'enfance c'est quoi ? deux petites feuilles en bas de celle ci !
la petite tige et les petales
tu voit GARDEN ( jardin )
MAIS NON ! on dirais la coupe de ta grand mère si je fait sa !
non, mais heu... MAIS NAN
un ventilateur ! *reflexion*
bah c'est un peu comme une fleur ! *rire*
HOP, HOP, HOP le tout
dans la grille qui protège ta tête la !
vuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuu ( bruit de ventilateur ) et heu..
le pied qui tient le ventilateur !
il a trouvé , il a trouvé ! un bracelet!
alors, sa c'est le bras, avec les poils que ta
hérité de ton père et sa c'est le bracelet ! il voit...
UN TÉLÉPHONE, UNE CLARINETTE ???? mais arête !
voila alors regarder y'a le petit.... ho putain mais il est nul
mais c'est quoi ce robot la ? je te fait un caribou il serai mieux sans deconner
une STAR ! t'a l'heure il l'avais vu
alors HOP, HOP, HOP, HOP, HOP c'est
finalement comme un shuriken, comme une fleur, comme un ventilateur !
*rire*, on a fait le même dessin trois fois pour trois
trucs différent ! UNE MOTO chui motard je vais  pas
vous mentir je vais m’appliquer !
*musique épique*
*voir cheloux : it's motorbike*
j'ai pas eu le temps de finir *rire*
vous l'avez éduqué pour qu'il reconnaisse les trucs PAR CONTRE pour etre poli
sa sa y va de...de... plus personne !
*étonnement de soi même*, faut jamais que je m'énerve contre mes
enfants ils vont exploser de rire bah il a tous trouver sauf ma fleur
qui ressembler a une carotte ouais c'est ouais c'est
mon étoile il la reconnu il voyais un avion aussi
dans mon étoile ! a regardez on peu les autres mecs qui ont dessiné
des étoiles attend lui il a trop cru que c'était un pokémon il a fait
stary le mec... AAA oui la technique d'enfant ! putain !!!!
j'y avais pas pensé !! Ok un bouchon de bouteille !
un bouchon a vissé ou un bouchon heu...
de champagne en liege ?
Question importante, ok donc bouchon
c'est sa ! donc la t'a la bouteille la !
bouteille de... attend je t'aide vite fait !
voila tu reconnais pas ??? aaaa nan mais vite !!!
un bouchon, c'est un bouchon, un bouchon *soupir*
UN OISEAU ! j'aimerais bien réussir un dessin
un jour ! je pense déjà faut commencer par l'aile
tu sais c'est comme du poulet chez toi a midi !
j'arete pas de faire des comparaison, c'est chiant !
*reflexion* il avais trouvé ???
il avait trouvé ?? mais j'ai même pas fini de dessiné dessiner mon oiseau que...
*rire : il a trouvééé !!* j'ai fait l'aile il a reconnu !
faut faire un nuage ! a bah la c'est un petit peu comme la fleur !
le ventilateur et le reste, finalement on va pas se mentir !
VOILAAAAAA *rire*
haaaaa il peut te demander de dessiner un micro
tu fait juste qui se répète comme pour la fleur le nuage et tout
et ya pas de problème, il va trouver !
y'avais pas de blague, pas de blague dans ce que j'ai dit ! c'est abuser !
un trombone ! c'est plus dur que sa en a l'air ! alors mec normalement sa commence comme sa !
alors... C'EST UN TROMBONE !!!
mais comment on fait UN TROMBONE !! c'est un trombone un peu
plié qu'on a joué avec qu'on a crocheter la serrure de ta
soeur pour lui voler son journal intime ! *rire*
c'est trop chiant c'est comparaison ! putain
on c'est bien debrouillé a celle la ! ha bah si trombone !
bah il a reconnu ! il a dit paper clip c'est un trombone ?
haaaa nan !!!!!!!! trombone l'instrument !!!
falais faire ! haaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaa ha merdee ! putain !
mais sinon il avait reconnu quand même le trombone
comme je le voyais donc chuuuui
allez allez ! UN SKULL ! mec j'avais une technique pour
dessiner les cranes ! ok c'est bon !
popsicle ??? ( marque de pop glacé ! ) que quoi ???
un popsicle ... quesque c'est un popsicle ? alors attend...
même..
même google lui même ne sais pas
rondelle de hockey ? alors la on va mettre une pérspéctive 3D !
oooo c'est booo !! ho mais attend !
on dirais un bracelet ! j'ai fait un bracelet merde !
efface tout ! regarde la rondelle ! regarde la rondelle !
regarde la ! elle est la, elle est la !
une carottes ?? mais attend  comment on faire une ? a mais oui !
avec la fleur de t'a l'heure je m'en souviens ! comme sa !
et ta juste a faire des sortes de petites plantes
petites feuilles ! voila ! voila ! il est fort ! UN OEIL
un oeil comment on fait un oeil ? bah on fait un rond avec un point
dedant et c'est un oeil !
HOCKEY PUCK ( rondelle de hockey ) mais non ! il voyais
le truc de hockey ! mais c'est un oeil ! mais pourquoi tu vois
il voit un peanut !( noix ) il voit une cacahuète : (oui il c'est trompé dans la traduction ! )
alors que j'ai fais un oeil ! j'i pas comprit la par contre...
les autres ils ont ait quoi ? attend d'ou tu reconnais
lui mais tu reconnais pas le miens ? c'est du foutage de gueule !
non j'avoue  *ricanement*
allez reconcentre toi : 6/6 !!!
ventilateur !
ho nan et voila allez ventilateur ! ventilateur allez !
alllezzzz please
c'est un ventilateur ! mais il a tous vu !
il a marqué : le nuage, la fleur ! tous les trucs
qui hennnn..... une CLOTURE?
barrière ou palissade ! sa va etre trèèès
duur ! attend je sais comment on va faire une palissade
américaine
ooooooo ouiiiii
ho nan il en reste un ! UN CANON !
nan mais c'est un canon sa se voit !
nana mais la part contre sa se vois ! c'est un CANON !
tiens regarde c'est fille elle est canon ! mdr heu
un canon ! un canon c'est quoi c'est sa !